you  what happens to us makes us who we are  it's in the past it doesn't mean you  need to bear it  kind of meeting with your publisher we  love pages runs  you want to write a new look true crime  scene writers have a way of spinning  things the way they want  I came to see my son why he obviously  hate me I was doing my best we're hiding  with your replacement family  remember this total this Mustang just  not how I remember it because you have a  convenient way of remembering things all  the anger all the hatred the truck  I don't wanna scare away this character  my son ladies and gentlemen the  storyteller what a joke you people are  all feelings you deserve to be played  fallen for this nonsense our father  deaths what he has to do to protect his  children  if you understand that you understand  everything  you want to tell me so bad any looking  for me  to truth  you